the Joe Rogan experience it's hard to be
comfortable with yourself so it's very
hard to be comfortable with other people
that's why I always stress with people
like you've got to accept yourself for
what you've done wrong do your best and
also find some difficult [ __ ] to do
because that gets away a lot of the
anxiety that you carry around in your
body a lot of like difficult things make
regular life less difficult and it
sounds so simplistic but particularly
physically difficult things because when
you do things that are physically
difficult the strain of making yourself
do those things it's very valuable it's
not just valuable like exercise and
fitness and martial arts and running and
whatever you're doing that's really
difficult it's not just valuable in
terms of like health and the way you
look but it's also valuable for your
mind maybe even more so because regular
life can be confusing and little things
that go wrong and little problems that
arise or exacerbated by the fact that
you're not accustomed to dealing with
hardship so creating your own [ __ ]
whether it's through [ __ ] it's some
brutal kettlebell exercise or running up
hills or something is extremely valuable
for you also not not just accepting the
nuanced perspectives of other people but
also being able to navigate through this
world with some sort of an understanding
of just how complex it all is and how
weird it all is and and not be overly
thrown off by every little dip in the
road and pothole that you encounter
[Applause]